[Music]
uh uh don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate say hey babe hey bab hey babe
hey bab
[Music]
[Laughter]
hey hi everybody it's the Ian Finance
takeover of hey babe that's right I'm
your old pal Ian
and Chrissy and S are stuck somewhere on
the verizo and the tone and Chris goes
you got to get there at 10 a.m. we got
to be early we got a tight ship and so I
get here and it's just me and pimpy
hanging out and I'm I couldn't be
happier because they're doing taste buds
after this and to Roa on the phone
yesterday goes we got to keep it really
tight I got a tight schedule so this is
the best I'm sitting here I'm dangling
my feet like I'm on a kid on a roller
coaster and they had me come at 8:00
a.m. for what so you could sit here with
your thumb up your ass oh I had to I had
to carve the taste buds pumpkins since
8:00
a.m. but how have you been man let's
check in with Ian how's Ian good let's
do the song first you want to do the
song let's do it what do you got oh all
right since it's my show I'm going to
make up my own song and it's going to C
and and and it's got to end with babe
right that's the
yes we're sitting in the office having
fun I woke up and I saw the sun Chrissy
and S they're running late but it's Ian
take it over hey babe love it that was
beautiful thank you that was beautiful
buddy thank you now I did I'd love to
hear about your Renaissance Fair
Excursion that was top of my mind dude
let me tell you something we've been
having the time of our lives on being
with George
we are having the best time we're doing
silly fun things and we decided let's go
to the New York Renaissance Fair
Jordan's gonna We dressed up we dressed
up we brought our old pal Luke monz he
was a wizard great renaissance fair type
stuff Jordan was a maiden gorgeous
beautiful and I dressed up as Aus
Bowers because yeah baby I got lost in
my time baby and if I'm being honest I'm
escaping the 60s because consent wasn't
very important back then baby I'm
escaping a series of me too
shagadelic I got a little to shagadelic
at groovy baby
yeah were you well received this awesome
p dude people loved it it was amazing
and I don't know what is in My DNA maybe
it's from being a dirty Delaware doozy
but I am just predisposed to being good
at carnival games you go to the beach
with me we're on a boardwalk you're my
babe we're walking away with one of
those huge things you got an armful of
stuff I say we should give it to a kid I
go up and go do you want this and then
the family goes
no and dude there were so many carnival
games I won the Feats of Strength you
know Luke monz right of the tree trunk
of a human this tall guy right he's
digging the thing can't get you know the
Dinger the thing that you hit and it
go you know yeah well he hits it and
it's like it it there are all these
different levels right and he hits a one
and it goes up to
py and then he hit it again it went up
to not a real man and then Jordan goes
up and she hit it further than Luke
which is so funny but uh you know and
then there's like a big crowd because
you know Austin Powers is like yeah baby
do baby yeah and then it's my turn and
dude I hauled off on this mother cuz
nobody knows how to chop wood you you
smack the Mallet like you're chopping
wood are you practicing Wood shopping
you ever go what do you do wood shopping
sorry yeah in Williamsburg I'm chopping
wood on the street are you from
Pennsylvania you might chop some wood
from I just said I'm a dirty Delaware
doozy there's no fireplace in Delaware
the hell goes on in Delaware are you
listening to a word I'm saying first you
accused me of being for Philly which
thank you that they lost last night but
I still love you bless uh and then
you're like he here firewood in Jersey
or what you
say no I grew up camping so I learned
how to do firewood chopping and stuff
when I was little and uh we go we go up
to a YT Upstate and uh Wes the guy that
did our theme song from The Lumineers he
is two Yurts on a plot of land and he
just leaves me the keys and I go up
there it's it's amazing so we me Jordan
and our friend Taylor went up there had
a great time but you know I was chopping
wood up there oh chopping Wood's a good
workout for sure for sure that's why
when they do CrossFit they take a big
sledgehammer and hit a a tire
true yeah I mean and also your body in a
wife beater chopping wood but i' I said
this at Santino's birthday your body and
a wife beater outstanding you know you
said that and it really stuck in my
brain I want to thank you for that
because that was nice to say and I'm
shooting a special December 3rd oh
congrats The Cutting Room December 3rd
two shows 700 to 9:30 p.m. eat.com for
tickets New York City let's go first
special and I thought should I film this
in a wife
beater and jeans and just be like my
true glomba self oh that's kind of fun
big belt buckle like you got on today oh
yeah just Buckle it up I'm not going to
lie I'm going on YouTube I'm seeing that
thumbnail I'm clicking it right yeah I
mean who's not that's hilarious
wet so dude if F first of all it's so
funny you were like are you chopping
wood in Brooklyn I had a therapist once
who was like you got to get your anger
out why don't you go home and chop some
wood and I'm like what unless I find a
homeless man named wood like there's
nothing around me to chop what are you
talking about dude so dude I'm telling
you I take this Mallet and I just
and it goes three qus to the top and
everyone's like what the this Austin
Powers can swing what is happening and
they're like whoa I do it again a little
higher and they're like
whoa and then I'm like yeah baby yeah I
start playing the Mallet like a guitar
to get everyone going and then dude I
just and this thing pops and hits the
Dinger and I throw the Mallet like Ken
griffy junr hitting w home run and and
man that that really every time I want
to kill myself I think of that moment
I'm not going to lie though you feel
like the secretly the manliest comedian
very masculine comic thank yeah yeah
just a compliment for a friend I
appreciate that cuz mad him there's
nothing manlier than that it's coming
it's in Vogue are you taking it back
you're like never mind no no I'm kidding
that was a bit gross and I'll I will say
so that's on your patreon and I saw you
went skydiving on your patreon you have
the best patreon I think right now
you're the sweetest dude this is anytime
I get depressed I'm saying let's go I'm
going to meet up with with pimpy Mikey
and I'll tell you to get there at 8:00
a.m. and then so you have hours to think
of
compliments know it is funny I feel like
I am like super masculine but in like a
uh very like not a feminine but I'm like
uh very in touch with my feelings I
don't pull no no punches and I I really
give that up to like uh hardcore music
interesting like hanging around with a
bunch of tough guys but seeing how like
Alpha and dumb that is so like I'll
knock someone out to tell them to like
tell their friends they love them
more it's a hidden masculinity it's
inside well dude so many comics and like
if if something's happening like dude
one time at the Knitting Factory his guy
ran up on one of the comics and yanked
the mic out of her hand and there's no
security no one's doing nothing and uh
this uh everyone's like oh no what do we
do and I'm like you know I I feel like
Peter wenman and Ghostbusters 2 when
he's like you know sometimes
happens and who you going to call I'm
like me so me and Scotty chaplain run up
and he's Jersey trash you know he's got
half a brain you know from like chopping
chickens for his whole life so he's just
like did that cluck I'm a CH head off
and so dude me and him run up on him and
the guy grabbed the mic and and he hops
up on the table and he starts to pull
his pants down and we're like what the
so we run up on him and uh if somebody
like mouths off to me I'm like Mr
deescalate like hey let's whatever like
I'm very like you know I don't want to
whatever but if I I don't know what it
is but if someone does something to like
a friend of mine or if I see someone
like mouthing off to a friend do you
know that place Krabby dicks or like
dicks dicks Krabby Cafe that no it's a a
place in Vegas it's like uh CRA dicks in
Vegas let it's it's called like dicks no
they they insult you oh the restaurant
that insults you I forget what yeah
Dick's Last Resort that's the one so
dude me Jordan our friend Brit and uh
our friend Taylor we go to Dick SL
Resort right it's like we're at
skankfest and they're like oh it's a
place to eat let's go we're hungry I'm
like all right so I the you know a bit
about this right like the whole staff
they insult you right they insult you
that's like their gimmick like you go in
and and then you sit they make you wear
a hat and they throw at you right I
don't know
this I don't know this so we go in and
there's kind of an effeminate overweight
gay man that's like uh hello and I'm
like H and they're like hi is the
kitchen still open and he goes they're
seating at the bar the kitchen's not
open go sit down I'll decide if I want
to wait on you and I'm like excuse me
and and he insulted Jordan and I'm like
what and then he goes what are you the
tattoo man what are you covered in
tattoos are you the tattoo man I go what
the did you just say and Jordan
goes no no it's okay so the kitchen's
not open and I go yeah the kitchen's not
open because you probably ate all the
food you fat and he
goes why'd you say that and I go don't
say to my friends and he goes
that's that's what we're supposed to do
and they're like Ian no no no that's why
it's called dicks everyone's a dick and
he goes you know I got to be honest I've
been feeling really bad about myself
lately and I'm like no no no no no I'm
sorry I thought you were just being mean
to my friends so I hugged him he gave
him $20 and I'm like I'm so sorry I'm so
sorry
$20 for your
wounds I'm like yeah maybe you could buy
a diet shake with that one fatty
oh I'm
sorry what's the worst situation you've
ever gotten in defending a friend well
the this thing at the Knitting Factory
all these people like stop stop and and
me and Scotty run up and the guy Scott
goes to grab the mic and the guy pushes
Scott and dumps a beer on him and I'm
like so I just grab and knock
him in the face and he falls off the
table and then security like ran in by
that someone ran out got security they
Converge on them and the mesh came up
and was like you should probably get out
of here that's assault and I was like
good
point you know and uh but he said it you
know he does black voice so he's like
yeah this is so and I was like
you're right brother man so uh I love
you NE Mas so I like out the
door and I'm just you know out of
there apparently they got him outside
and then a bunch of like open micers
from the creek started popping off to
him like you can't do that blah blah and
apparently the guy was like in the IDF
at one point and dude he beat the
out of like four guys he took his thumb
and put it in some kids throat and I
just snuck him and I'm like do
and this guy wrecked house on all these
[Laughter]
sh so I'm a man
secretly yeah oh God but no I want to
know about skydiving what the was
oh dude that's very nice yeah the
patreon's doing uh we're we're having
fun man people are really digging it we
just did a watchalong party with a
Beetle Juice how fun yeah so we're going
to start watching movies and like uh you
know whatever I'd love to know like I've
never done skydiving are you nervous I
saw it's an hour of special so you got
to go like how what's your fear what's
your what is St Chris texted me did you
know that poor sleep can cause weight
gain mood issues poor mental health and
lower productivity did you know that and
that sleeping less than six to seven
hours per night is linked to a reduced
white blood cell count white blood cells
protect our body against illnesses and
diseases finding virus and bacteria
sleep is the foundation of our mental
physical health and performance in our
days having a consistent nighttime
routine is nonnegotiable that's why I
want to talk to you about beam dream you
know we've been raving about beam's
dream powder their healthy hot cocoa for
Sleep remember s would always talk about
this how much he loved this and he would
pass right out and I love it too I used
it it first of all the dream the bean
dream powder hot cocoa it tastes amazing
the TA it's like the best tasting hot
cocoa I've ever had and today my
listeners get a special discount on
beam's dream powder they're bestselling
healthy hot cocoa for sleep with no
added sugar now available in delicious
flavors like sea salt caramel cinnamon
cocoa and chocolate peanut butter better
sleep has never tasted better a Rec
clinical study revealed dream helped 93%
of users wake up feeling more refreshed
and 93% reported that dream helped them
get a more restful night sleep if you
want to try beams bestselling dream
powder get up to 40% for a limited time
when you go to go when you go to shop
beam.com heyab and use the code heyab at
checkout that's shop beam
be.com heab use the code heyab for up to
40% off find out why Forbes and New York
Times are all talking about beam and why
it's trusted by the world top athletes
and business professionals go to sleep
get bean butcher box I love butcher box
that butcher box first of all it is
fresh meat delivered right to your door
it has all butcher box has all you need
for a tasty stressfree holiday season
with high quality protein delivered to
your door I love butcher box the last
day to order a turkey for Thanksgiving
is November 12th 2023 folks November
12th 2023 that's the last day to get a
turkey so get on it now listen what do
you think about it what are your
favorite holiday meals activities
Traditions what do you like you like you
like turkey you like roasting a lamb you
like a big fat meatloaf whatever it is
Butcher box has the meat to get you
covered butcher box is something that
you know I've been using it to cook meat
for my family I love the prep work I
love cook I didn't realize until I
started using butcher box how much
cooking helps you bond with your family
and how much you burn your fingertips
because I I when I moved I didn't have I
didn't pack my I didn't pack my um oven
mitts so I just take paper towels and I
try to grab hot plates and stupid and I
burn my fingertips but it doesn't matter
because the meat and butcher box taste
so good I forget about that my
fingertips are burnt and they look like
the tops of Jim Norton's head this
holiday season is made better by butcher
box for a limited time they're offering
our listeners turkey free in your box
you're going to get turkey in your box
you're getting stuffed turkey in your
box in for free plus $20 off your first
order all you have to do is sign up
today at butcherbox.com
heyab and use the code heyab to get this
deal butcherbox.com heab use the code
heyab to get this deal turkey free in
your box for $20 off your first order go
do it what's up everybody I got a brand
new hour of material then November 2nd
in uh Pittsburgh November 3rd Detroit
November 4th Columbus Ohio November 10th
and 11th daa Beach Florida then we got
New Haven Connecticut Providence and
Medford followed by Phoenix Arizona Salt
Lake City and Denver and then we've
added San Diego LA and Reno Nevada
Washington DC and Nashville for the new
year Christy comedy.com for Ticky wikies
let me tell you something come see this
material because after I am done with
this tour I will not be on the road for
probably close to a year so if you want
to see me Now's the Time to do it
Christy comedy.com get your tickets as a
gift get them for you we have a good
time this is the material I'm the most
proud of so come out see you I'll kiss
you on the lips what's up guys real
quick tour dates are on sale right now
at salvano comedy.com there's a big
Illinois run in November leading up to
my comedy special at the Vic in Chicago
on December 1st and 2nd I'm sorry I
wasn't paying attention to you because
Chris said he probably only going to do
15 minutes but he'll make it
count welcome to chos I love it I love
it wait is this hey babe or chy chaos
hey bab or babe chaos bab I me what are
you going to do I don't know what's
going on today I love it I couldn't be
happier to be here with you and just be
alive in in in in America always a good
hang always a good hang but there's no
fear with skydiving it's just more FES
to six hours for
something six hours how long did it take
you have to drive there what it an hour
in Long Island no this is in Austin oh
we were down there doing the podcast at
moon tower and we're like dude let's go
I ran at a truck got got us of this
thing it was 45 minute drive really fun
you know we had to go early in the
morning we get there it's honestly it's
maybe 2 to 3 hours you you have to go
through like you have to obviously sign
all this paperwork you have to you know
get yelled at by a Butch lesbian woman
that gets mad at you for smoking and not
putting your cigarette butt out in the
designated smoking area which they don't
have any signs for and then you're rude
to her because you haven't had your
coffee yet and then you remember that
other people exist except yourself so
you go up to them and make amends and
apologize and hug each other and then
find out she's the one you're skydiving
with so that's fun part of
it that makes sense so then you got to
sit through a video like a 20 minute
video where they explain stuff to you
and you're like I get it I get look
you're you're skydiving with someone so
you're you're you're with someone they
do everything so it's like dude I I get
I'm just jumping out of a plane and a
guy's holding on to me like you know but
they got to cover everything everything
you know to have to watch their
so then this guy comes on the the video
and he totally looks like a Doomsday
prepper like he looks like a sex cult
leader in the woods like he looks like
you if your beard was longer and you had
a ponytail and you like I'll get there
you know were were just like making
people like in your cabin you know which
three to five years yeah I join I join
the C and pimp it's on Co little outfits
you'd be a great cult
leader I've always said that about you
that's very nice thank you but I I
would I I couldn't do the sex
thing yeah it's weird have you watched
the doc where like the guy has he
manipulates the whole family into
sleeping with him it's a crazy Doc it's
on I think Netflix even the father who
is straight flips and then falls in love
with
him good great Doc and have you seen the
other dock where a a guy runs a haunted
mansion where he actually waterboards
you oh in New York New York City
blackout right no this is like a it's on
Hulu it's some guy called his it's
called Monster but no you go to Virginia
and he hides your phone and you
disappear for a week and he tortures you
and a it's just a guy it's just a weird
dude and he started a cult of people who
like being
tortured this is what happens when you
turn into a secular
country Christian Ian yeah yeah that's
my call when you J to your knees pop the
out your mouth and pray to
Jesus um so how' it feel to actually
fall from a
plane well dude so you you learn all
this stuff and then you go you get
fitted for your thing and then a guy
talks to you and he's very much like a
father figure type and you get uh An
Itch in your brain to make him like you
so you keep cracking jokes and he
doesn't laugh and then your friend
Jordan picks up on the fact that he
hates you and then he realize that's the
man you're strapped to and his lesbian
haircut wife is the one filming us and
uh it was the cutest thing ever dude oh
my God so we get in the thing and we get
in the plane and uh me and my guy he's
sitting behind you're like basically
like nuts to butts and he's you know um
sitting behind me and he could have used
a toothbrush that morning but I'm just
grateful that you know he knows what
he's doing and uh so Jordan is next to
me and we're like holding hands and like
nervous we're like laughing we're so
excited and his his wife who's a
videographer she has a camera on her
head she's in front of us and dude
they're married they've been doing this
like 25 years and it was so cute because
before we jumped out they did a sec
handshake and then they kissed each
other's hand as a thing of
like if pops off I love you goodbye
I feel like you and Jordan need a a
handshake kiss like that we did we
imitated their thing and uh it it was
like so nice and uh you know I could
whenever I want to like feel like good
like if if I ever want a good cry I
listen to 911 tapes of people calling
their family any time there's a last
phone call like The Place Beyond the
Pines when he calls and like leaves a
message good God do I start crying so
I'm like oh that's so sweet so then we
are about to jump out of the plane and
I'm like you know what I'm ready
dude I suggest everyone do it because if
you have a fear I feel like you should
do the thing that scares you to get
through it to get through the
uncomfortability and get on the side of
comfortable and you realize if I can
jump out of a plane and and live and
make it work and be okay I could get
through anything you know just look at
any piece of adversity as skydiving
you're scared you got to push through it
and you got to parachute and you land
safely and you you walk away and all
your fears they exist but they don't
come true and they don't even have to be
real and the problem of you think you're
going to die and this and that that
doesn't exist all our problems haven't
even happened yet you know it's about
perception wow that's cool yeah so you
should join my cult let's do it I'll
have sex with
you you're not type shave and get a
suntan and then we'll talk well I'll
just pass on that well you're not
allowed in my cult speaking of uh new
relationships were you were at skankfest
did you see uh what was your review of D
Ro his action there bro anytime someone
becomes a friend to five Dan I'm I I
salute him and I'm ready to welcome him
to the club you know it's so it that
that was interesting to me
because he did a thing that I've been
doing since I was
19 and the way people reacted was always
my fear of just like laughing and making
fun and like people shitty dude everyone
mentioned it every comic
everyone oh there she is oh that D Roa
and and it was like the running joke of
the weekend to the point where I'm on um
my wife hates me right and the jokes
start coming and they're funny whatever
but uh they keep saying stuff and
obviously I I'm like you finally F
you know they're like what do you think
I go oh what about to Roa finally for
the first time in his life being cool
I'm like you're all losers this is the
we're the future you analog
I think it does give him
like an Elegance it it gives some kind
of charm I'll I'll say I was you know
taken a back because at a certain point
I'm like this she's a person what are we
doing she's has feelings you know it's
not just a I love jokes but it was like
what's happening oh I didn't know it was
like that for him well well I'll say
this so I said to a friend at at one
point I had this thing inside me there
was like I should run up and be like
stop it stop it this is a person I'm
like that's that's not my role I
shouldn't do that I was being emotional
and I get to check that at the
door so I go to a friend I go this is
such a lesson I go I feel like I should
say something to everyone to defend her
and she goes you can do that if you want
but you have to ask yourself are you
doing that for her or are you doing it
for you and I go oh I'm doing that
for me your own ego this is my own
my own ego my own savior complex and I
go dude thank you for loving me enough
tell me the truth and not just be like
Rob yes someone neat you know so like
man thank God so I checked in with her
personally cuz I I know her we've been
friends for for since like the past two
skankfest yeah so we talk a fair amount
whatever yeah I didn't know it was a
negative thing
were making it it wasn't negative it was
just like tons of jokes but after a
while if you get ripped on for the same
thing it's like all right man I F get it
you know and and I'm like you know
literally she's in the front row and
like that's the one and everyone laughs
and she's taking it like ha so I'm like
oh my God is this person like you know
coming down here and they feel like
they're being like attacked not my place
to to make a stink but I checked in with
her I was like hey how you doing are you
having fun she's like I am having the
best time I'm feeling so much love and I
was like that's all I wanted to hear
amazing you know I hugged her and was
like Hey I love it happy for you the
best cool as long as you're all right
you know but even then it's like not if
she was like I I'm everyone and I'm
scared it's not my place to be like I'll
fix it it's just my place to be like hey
I I love you and it's okay and then be
like it's all love it's all blah but she
picked up on it right right and then I
thought the cutest like sweetest thing
was after a weekend of like being joked
at and like the butt of a joke D Roa and
her D roza went on stage and sang time
of my life I saw that and he brought her
on stage everybody went nuts included
her in the bit spun her around proposed
and it was like such a wonderful moment
of like oh yeah that's what this is
jokes and we all joke and it's the end
of the day it's all love and that was
like beautiful to see and I really love
that and uh I mean d Ro is full-blown
gay we can all admit that it's a new era
I'm just proud of him it's it's cool
yeah who gives a it's the best I've
never seen him happier I'll tell you
that no for real
bro let live your best life do
the thing you've always wanted to do as
long as you're not being like a piece of
about it you know for real and uh
it's I love like um there there's this
gal I've been uh you know hooking up
with and uh you know
fun not vintage oh okay new gal oh girl
2.0 wow upgraded boobs and
a you know a gal for the new era dope
and so um my favorite thing to do she's
she's super hot is to show her to my
friends and be like Yo dude isn't this
chick hot they're like oh my God she's
so hot and then I show her penis cuz
she's a porn store and uh and I go haha
you're gay forever and they're like
What's Happening you know I don't get
why people show up tight who cares
whatever I mean I don't know it's like
conditioning or some but you
got to push through that you just you
just got to skydive in your own
mind you become a Skydive self-help
author but I but I'm I'm I'm I go
nowhere past digging deeper than
skydiving I everything is skydiving like
everything is like you know like I'm
going through a divorce imagine it like
jumping out of a plane like I get it now
what now what you stupid repeater it
might be more helpful than your log
chopping therapist oh yeah there's
nothing worse than a bad therapist bro
dude I therapist years ago and
he was working on a sliding scale
okay you know what that is uh for his
rate M okay how much he gets done how
much he gets paid that kind of thing so
when some when a therapist has a private
practice even if they're in another
practice you can go to them and be like
hey I'm not financially able to afford
this what can you do to work with me and
when people go therapy is too expensive
it's like no dude you you just ask them
just ask say look I need this this but I
can't afford it haggle I love a good
haggle haggle fun oh I love haggle when
it works out bro and when it doesn't boy
is it embarrassing oh God boy what's the
worst thing you ever haggled for where
they're like we don't negotiate bro when
I me me and my ex I would send her out
of the room to be like I'll take care of
it but one time she didn't and I'm
haggling and the guy goes no and I go
come on come on what are you and he goes
no and I felt so impotent in front of
her like you know like it just felt like
such a fool you know there's nothing
better than the feeling of a hangle but
when you're like yeah well what about
this cash and they're like no I can't do
it and you're like what about this and
they go I said I can't do it you just
feel so small you're like okay I'll pay
full price you know and um so the
therapist was negotiating oh here it is
here it is
whoa yes welcome to the Ian Finance show
how you I like it Ian you needed to come
on and it couldn't have worked out
better the only bad news is is we're
going to put this episode out after your
special you are lying I will beat the
out of you dude no we got you we'll
move you up thank you so much you're the
best we appreciate it do take the
platform um you know it's it's slowly
falling apart as we do it and I'll play
The Voice Memos one day in court now now
listen listen
I we can only I can only stay on with
you for another 20 25 minutes cuz Joe do
roza has given me explicit instructions
that if I am not we are not out of this
studio by 11:30 that he said that he's
going to suck my and after Legion
of skanks I believe him dude you know
what let it happen now let me ask you a
question let me ask you a question now
Ian let it happen is there a little bit
of jealousy is there a little bit of
animosity towards Joe that now he's the
most famous bisexual
[Laughter]
comic no because I'm like trai and D Ro
is legit
gay fair enough folks in is is he
claiming he's by is he bisexual well cuz
I don't think if you're with a trans
person that makes you buy yeah maybe
he's not I don't know I feel like I feel
like um it's it's been a lot of fun to
watch kind of this sexual Revolution
happen in comedy cuz it it just kind of
anything goes and I'm with it yeah I
like that I just sorry I'm late I just
came I was supposed to be pimp and I
were talking yesterday I did Howard
Stern this morning no way are you
serious it baby dude did Howard Stern I
was only supposed to be on for 20
minutes so I was like I'll be here by 9:
I told you to be here promptly we'll do
it then this guy kept me on for like 2
hours no dude no no okay we talked about
everything like stories or whatever then
the last hour he brings out this guy who
had a genital mutilation fetish and
starts posting and we start going
through pictures of this guy putting his
exposed nut sack that he cut open on a
dinner plate nailing his to a wall
sticking squashes and apples and other
fall fun vegetables up his ass shout out
helloof fresh
um it it he he literally so I stayed and
it was in let me tell you something in
New York comedy I think you know you
could do the Letterman you know you one
day you know do the garden but I do
think Howard Stern getting on that show
when I was sitting there it's almost
that moment you're like oh I'm on
with Howard Stern right now like this is
because of my comedy so you're like okay
this is something so and I couldn't
believe he just kept asking me to stay
he was like do you have anywhere to go
and I was like
no yes yes dude that is the best that's
the C did Howard stir I did yeah I dude
you know what like I could not even
think I can't even think of a thing
that's more like that is yeah except my
my special Sunday December 3rd which is
going to be room which is and where
where is it again The Cutting Room The
Cutting Room which is where in New York
City yeah which is where I was at a
dinner once at the cutter I'm sorry I
was at a stage performance once and
guess who was sitting at the table next
to me is one and only Mr Harvey
Weinstein no y wow dude holy
speaking of genital mutilation did you
see his candle burned dick no I dude I'd
love to after after seeing what I saw
today the man that we had on today Frank
who was on the Howard Stern Show had a
bated cut his down the middle sorry
he cut his hay bab down the middle we
don't curse on the show he cut his hay
bab down the middle shout out Harry's
raisers he sh uh sh cut his uh penis
down the middle and he removed his
testicles he has no balls and he cut his
penis down the middle as a bifurcated
penis a two-headed Serpent and um he
loves it he said when he was a young boy
I knew it I knew it I knew it when he
was about 9 years old he said what
happened was is he um he was you know
fooling around with a girl another
nine-year-old and the mother walked in
this girl's mother walked in and he was
shoving erasers in her vagina he was
taking pencil erasers and putting them
in her vagina and she was like you know
you little freak like what kind of
fetish do you have and he's like Mom
said that to him I think that it just
you know this was like the whatever 60s
he was like I he was an older man now
he's like I think it just planted in my
head that I'm a I'm a I'm a dirty little
boy and I have a fetish and then that
one day or another and then that led to
cutu him literally shoving full apples
up his where you had to get them
emergency removed cut to cutting out his
testicles and putting them on a dinner
plate and having other guys eat a dinner
while he has got his nuts on the plate
um so it it it gets weird
quick Jesus that's what it is what were
you guys talking
[Music]
about well Ian had Ian learned a lot
about himself skydiving oh did you wait
wait what how why a pencil in her
well it was an eraser and I was think
eraser and I said to him I said do you
think it was you erasing her vagina and
wishing that it was maybe a penis or
something else he goes you know in 30
years of therapy I've never thought
about that but that could be it I was
like well all I could do is thank better
.c forgetting me there you know you know
what it is he just probably found the
only thing in the room that was
available I shoved a space pen on my ass
when I was in sixth grade you know I
can't get a dildo well I Adam
andeve.com shout him out go see the
special December 3rd yeah b.com for
tickets I I I I think though too what I
was getting from this guy is that you
know when you're a child right you know
young your brain's forming like a couple
of things that could be what what was
otherwise a mundane Tuesday shaped your
entire life when it it was just like if
he was in a different state of mind or a
a day or two older or younger that would
have done nothing would have went went
out the other but it was the perfect
time yeah and the fact that she goes you
sick little freak what kind of fetish
you it's like dude my God I got a fetish
and I am a sick little freak oh yeah and
I like I like to in a bag and you
call me little shitty
cupcakes
sorry hey babe in a bag hey babe
cupcakes we we tried to this is our show
now let's be honest I'll play the
voicemail we tried to we tried to I need
to hear this we tried to make ice
cubes when we were in high scho cuz I
used to make a thing called a piss Puck
you ever hear that a piss Puck no but it
sounds good and happy hockey season
everyone it's begun go flyers I said
that
foran uh yeah you you uh piss in a uh
soda can only this much freeze it and
then cut the soda can okay cut it's
makes it a like hockey puck a piss and
you throw it in a door or put it in
someone's car window it melts and it
just piss I like that I like that that
and now and this is a Philadelphia thing
Delaware Delaware sorry but but you rep
Philadelphia yeah are you upset that the
Phillies lost last night I apologize bro
it was rough yeah what you do
where were you I was in New York comedy
club and I was about to go on stage and
Tommy Pope went on stage right when they
lost and he was
disassociating he was literally like
like uh dude have you ever you know that
Jeremiah Watkin show stand up on the
spot sure great show so Tommy went up
and he totally spaced and forgot to ask
for suggestions and was mumbling through
his act and and people were shouting out
and he's like what the and then he
kept going into his stuff and Jeremiah I
go what's up he goes dude I don't know
man he's on stage mumbling about
911 and he comes off and he goes I I
can't believe the Phillies lost and I'm
like dude it's it's not that like these
goddamn Diamond Backs they're the most
boring team they have no personality the
Phillies are all heart they're
what it's about and they just
know what a boring World Series now the
Texas Rangers versus the Arizona
Diamondbacks the only person who's happy
about the Diamondbacks winning is Sergio
shakon cuz love snakes that's it he was
like he goes yo good game last night Pop
I was like you want a Dbacks to win is
that all you knew watching with his Bo
Constructors yeah if I asked him what do
you know about the Diamondbacks he would
start reciting facts about the actual
snake not the team oh yeah it's amazing
you know during the pandemic I went to
Pal Meer PA with him on Father's Day to
so he could get a uh boa constrictor W
about your wife and child let's go with
Ian F Dan to the bows of PA and get a
snake yes dude
the best it was the best DBS DBS now
first of all Ian I haven't seen you well
I I feel like I here's the thing with
you with our friendship I feel like
maybe sometimes it could go upwards of
six months of me not seeing you but it
always feels like I saw you yesterday
yeah isn't that good I love that cuz you
got positive energy you know what kind
of guy you are you're the type of guy
that you have such good positive energy
that you can influence people and make
them happy when you're not even in the
room so someone can think about you and
say Ian made me happy now you know and
he may not be in the room with me I
don't know what he's doing he could
either be having sex with a woman or
getting fisted by a guy that's the coin
flip of thean Dan and that's what we
like we like to call him in this
business a wild card yeah and that's you
are the definition of that but I thought
you're the guy you make you you can
affect people's mood even when you're
not in the room cuz there's some people
that can affect people's mood negatively
when they're not in the room so if you
have the power not everyone has the
power to affect people's mood when
they're not in the room but you do and
you're doing it for good not for evil
you are the sweetest that's Jo is
completely the opposite of you I know I
know dude I talked to him on the phone
yesterday and we're we're talking you
know and I'm like uh first of all he
said something to me once he goes you
know I'll tell you in this business I'll
never forget one time jeie guad dupe
said this and that I go who the is
that and he's like she's an old Talent
Booker from 19 I'm like what the
are you talking about but I loved D Roa
and I was like I was like dude you're
the best I love you I always
love talking to you and he goes thank
you go you're the most miserable person
I know but I you know but I I love him
I'm so glad he's living happily I I feel
like uh Jim Norton walked so I could
crawl yes and I craw or no Jim Norton
crawled so I could walk and then I
walked so D Roa could run dude as soon
as salsa windfall his band wants to do a
scat cover you're in oh dude
dude that was so kind of you to say that
I really appreciate it man thank you go
see his show December 3rd at The Cutting
Room maybe Harvey Weinstein will be
there and by the way uh salsa winfall
live show the 28th of October of October
28th also windall is that the one is
that down at Arlene's grocery where is
it Google Google grer I'm going to be in
Raleigh North Carolina I'm seeing dude I
had a weekend and I changed it so I
could go see my favorite hardcore band
have a reunion in Philadelphia black
here's the thing here's here's here's
your choices Saturday October 28th you
could either go see Joe D Roa at perform
for salsa windfall in the basement of
some room in Pennsylvania or go see our
friend Nate bargoni host SNL so so which
pick which one would you prefer folks
they started out together and their
nights are just a little different I
love that the night that Nate's hosting
SNL he's doing salsa wifall that
pig Jo Roa that's what you deserve pig
boy and he's and he's got Jeffrey G and
dancing on stage
like he's got he JoJo Rose is bringing
up Jeffrey G and Nate's bringing up the
Foo
Fighters you piece of D Roa oh my
God holy good oh my God Joe's just
sobbing doing a cover of Everlong Bar's
with the B playing while Nate is
literally living his dream on an arena
tour
they started at the same
time started at the bottom even lower
than the bottom yes oh I love it dude I
love D Roa I love it good well that's
that's the world folks oh god well what
now belt buckle you've been going with
the this belt buckle look now and I
think you're bringing it back because
I've seen a lot of people with the belt
buckle since you've been doing it thank
you I appreciate that I got to tell you
you know what's Wild is uh I so I I
always wear like a turquoise and Native
American Jewelry I I love it I love
native am you're bisexual you've said it
yes yes
yes and I show it uh I love Native
American jewelry and spirituality and I
love Native American spirituality so
much I talked my way out of With a
Stripper by bringing it up and she
decided to leave oh my God so what do
you think of this flower Moon movie with
scorsi did you see it no I'm excited
it's about Native American have you seen
it no I haven't seen it but I would what
do we got pimp pimp pimp flashed us a
light D Rose is here should we just
bring him in let's bring Joe in for five
minutes yeah yes yeah cuz I got to meet
Colin Quinn for lunch at 11:40 so we got
to do the ads on zoomazing dude I
honestly I just have to say you being on
Howard's I could not be happier for you
that truly that is like the it's it's a
thing of like like you said Tonight Show
Letterman that's a thing that I think
doesn't even register as attainable to
Comics well that and and it's one of
those things where you know like my
manager was like you know he's been
doing this so long he might not be doing
it you know you don't you can't do this
stuff for 40 50 years like you got on
you thank God you got on because at any
day he could be like you know what
hanging it up because I mean what else
does Howard have to prove and for him to
go why don't you stick a rent that's
like it was nuts it was nuts because you
know you feel like you're bombing as you
know like on those things you feel like
you're telling these stor and and then
you think like okay just get to the end
try to get a punch line here and move on
and then I would get it it would you
know get a laugh and then he'd be like
wait wait but go back for a second let
wait tell me about that part and then he
kept doing that and I was like oh
he's listening cuz I thought he wasn't
listening yeah oh here we go were you
getting in the room boy would you have
any content if it wasn't for me anymore
all you do is talk about my life dude
did you he did you hear that outside no
P oh Jem dude it's definitely
the clip
it's definitely the we said on the we
said on the same night on the same night
you're doing a show at Sala windfall
Nate's hosted SNL you're bringing up
Jeffrey G and he's bringing up the food
Fighters yeah where are you going to be
that night Raleigh North Carolina it's
not sold
out dude I mean all you do is talk about
me on your shows anymore cuz I love you
dude yeah that's look who you're sitting
next to look at this balding Pig you I
take up for you you piece of he was
telling me how positive I am I'm turning
it around you you're gay now cuz
you the trans woman how's that feel
how's that feel I love it me too dude
that's by the way that's the name of
your new restaurant the balding Pig you
got to open one up in Pennsylvania the B
dude first of all you look good
what are you doing uh look at his
hairing best life dude I'm telling you
dude I'm not going to divulge
information no I'm not going to divulge
anything unless you say it but I think
it's because you moved out of a
situation A circumstance where you're
like feeling open and free you're
wearing it dude I'm telling you dude you
look no I swear to God you look like the
healthiest I've seen in a while you know
what it is it's it's I've been working
on something for about a month and I I
because I was needed to be clear
grooming a trans
woman also honestly no joke for the
Arlene show because we haven't played in
so long I was like I have to be clear so
for the whole month I haven't drank and
I AC I was telling you I accidentally
started intermittent fasting cuz I was
so like you could tell just working and
your hair looks better everything was
better thanks man but I think after
Saturday I'm going to go to and
start drinking I'll be your sponsor
this are steps to a wh housee one way or
another one way or another your life was
going to end up lonely and depressed in
central
Pennsylvania what does this Hat Knows
ewn concrete one of my favorite bands
our hardcore band from New Jersey they
got great albums time to shine the
second coming shout them out Aunt money
you're the best oh my God yeah dude
Jesus God it's so hot in here right I
know it really is yeah all right but uh
dude you guys look good too man I'm not
just saying that back but I can't take a
well I I I've got down to a large in
Lululemon so thank you do you know what
he just did what what Howard Howard
Stern I didn't know you meant like
literally just it no I did
this well I was saying because you know
we had a plan I said we you know we had
a we had a whole situation where we had
to be in here early and I was only
supposed to be on they said for 20
minutes and that's why I thought I could
be here at 9:00 a.m. but this guy kept
me on for two hours because they started
doing these dad this sex fetish um uh uh
uh segment where they had some guy you
know come out like on you know on a
video and just show his like he was like
he would cut open his nuts his scrot him
and put his testicles his bare testicles
on a plate um then he would like to get
like you know like rods shoved into his
dick he would be he would put a rod yes
that's what it is he would put one rod
on in his penis and you would have the
rod on the other end and then it would
kind of just each other so it just
turned into a thing where I was like
wait he would cut his nuts out of the
sack and put them on a plate nuts out
how do you not die if you do I don't
understand because because he just
control the blood somehow I I don't know
dude did you watch that Gotti
documentary on Netflix it just came out
it's called get Gotti he was the best
guy
around but what about all the murder
what
murder yeah no I didn't see is it good
yeah yeah it's pretty good I mean look
the story's been told so many times at
this point but what's interesting about
the documentary it's two things it's a
do series it's three episodes what's
what's interesting about those two
things it talks about the race to to put
him away and the competition on the
prosecuting side of it I never knew this
like like the police are after them like
set up the whatever sting operation can
the FBI is trying to get him the
District Attorney's office is trying to
they all compete with each other I never
knew that I thought law enforcement just
work together no they do not that's they
hate each other when a county comes into
the state they hate it CU they
want it to be our thing our so they get
into that they get into all the
different competing parties because it
it's like a case that will make your
career it'll it'll cement you forever
but on the crazier part is though
you know nowadays like with these mob
people like there's so many guys that
are just out now like they went away or
they testified or whatever whatever it
is but they're free to speak now like
it's not like it used to be where it was
like you never get out like there are
guys out there that can just talk there
are guys because they serve their time
they can't get busted they're admitting
the on this thing there's a guy
that talk and this is why I thought of
this a guy talks about he goes he he
goes my nickname was was uh unot or
whatever he's like cuz in Italian that
means crazy and he goes cuz I would do
crazy and he's like he dude he's
saying it like literally like he's
plugging your North Carolina gig he's
like's just like yeah it was crazy I
would just do like crazy stuff and
they're like like what and he goes
remember I got this one job this guy was
banging one of the maid guys wives you
don't do that he's like so I dressed up
as a UPS man and I went down to Florida
and I went into his house and I shoved
his girlfriend I had a package and
everything he goes I shoved the
girlfriend aside when she answered the
door and he goes I tied the guy to his
pool table and I cut his ball sack open
but he just FS it on camera like just
like it's like he's like he's ordering
lunch wow he's like kind of like he's
not like laughing like he's proud of it
he's just kind of being like yeah that's
just kind of what we did it was kind of
weird God like there are people on this
thing admitting crazy not admitting like
able to talk have you noticed that the
world kind of started going to when
they broke up the mafia and they stopped
they really put the kaios on
cigarettes no I didn't but it's
interesting I will agree with you I
don't think it's directly related to the
two things but I will say that I do
think byproducts of the culture
changing uh and like this this obsession
with with health and safety and it's an
obsession it's not just an interest that
those things are byproducts of it like
the thing with cigarettes like
cigarettes got so crazy cuz it was like
cigarettes are bad for you okay we got
to ban it in restaurants okay we got to
ban it in bars yeah okay secondhand
smoke is bad can't do it outside yeah
now you got to be this many feet from
the building tax you shouldn't be allow
to smoke in your car in case you have a
kid because then the kid could it just
became so insane like and and it's it's
a bu so I do think there's some
correlation between the event of the
stoppage of smoking and like the
cultural Shi and and also cigarettes
were a representation of listening to
people complaining yes like that was
like the oral you think now because they
don't have that outlet they just get mad
and it comes out in other way well yeah
and it also shows you oh if we complain
enough and like work hard we can stop
things that we don't like and at the
same time dude the mafia get off your
phone get off your phone the Mafia the
mafia uh kept people safe in a way there
was like order and people knew not to
around by the way that's built into
your conversation whenever you're
speaking get off your phone you're so
used to saying that the other person
just doing
it oh you that that should be the
name of your special get off your
phone please pay attention please call
get off your phone that's such a funny
St so dude if you don't name it that I
will and come out and have the audience
on their phones when you walk out and be
like get off your phone have them have a
shot of them putting their phones away
you know this guy one time goes no I'm
not this isn't a bit you should really
lean into how your name sounds like
Finance yes I was kidding Oh I thought
you were serious no the joke was that I
was going this isn't a bit it was such a
shitty idea that I was like pitching you
this terrible idea was a and then he saw
the look in your face and he made it a
shitty idea that's what happened I
called
him I called him and I go you should
lean into the fact that your name your
last name sounds like finance and you
should go on stage and do like a thing
where you give people funny Financial
advice I me it's not a bad idea but I'm
like of course of course he's he's he's
got this idea he named his band salsa
windfall it's like yeah why wouldn't he
suggest this the uh no no it was I
thought that would get a bigger laugh in
the room the bit was the bit people like
the band what can I tell you dude I like
the band that's the thing me and S me
and S were sitting in here trying to
on it just for fun and we were like
we kind of like actually just want to
keep listening to this goddamn album
good stuff you were trying to on it
s wasn't or at least s claims he wasn't
dude it's it's good yeah I guess I money
I'll say I'll say it on camera right now
in front of everybody s
eyes R
Salada all right I got to go got start
love youbud go ahead dude the best
congrats man
that's check his special out get there
to The Cutting Room in New York cityan
finance.com come out can I plug yeah
yeah yeah we're going to probably put
this out sooner than later right because
we got to get out before December 3rd
next week all right well the TL no
November 9th KGB bar where I'm doing the
readings from the audio book uh for New
York Comedy Festival and then November
11th TLA there's only a little bit of
tickets left for Philly so please come
out to that and then I got a bunch of
other dates joa.com please come out I
love go Christy comedy.com I got
Pittsburgh Detroit Columbus uh we just
put La the wilt turn so it's a uh big
one need you guys there San Diego Reno
Nevada Christy comedy.com for tickets
sorry to slide back we just announced
grammar New York grar janary go see him
Joey D at grammar I think it's January
something oh I can't make it um I I want
to thank you uh I know you squeezed me
in especially to get this out for my
special and you guys are always so kind
of me and I really appreciate that I
love you buddy thank
you don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey bab hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey bab hey babe